hello my friends it's Clements here with
the preview of dust palace an exclusive
stripe coming to destiny on PlayStation
what's a strike well I'm so glad you
asked i happen to know such things a
strike is a specialized mission in
destiny where you and two friends group
up to form a fireteam and work your way
through various objectives in long form
jam sessions set aside 20 to 30 minutes
for this my friends because strikes are
deep engaging and they pony up sweet
loot if you survive which you totally
will because you're a consummate
professional dust palace is set on Mars
and available at level 18 they're all
yours these not so friendly types are
called the Cabal they're digging into
the ancient city of freehold to find
this a I wore mine and do all sorts of
diabolical stuff with it you and your
friends as guardians are here to stop
them now the Cabal have deployed several
enemy units into dust palace in order to
end your do-gooding the legionary are
standard infantry so I trust you can
handle them but there are also some
field commanders in the mix known as
Centurions we'll try and pin you behind
cover so Frankham shangem and reposition
to battle these heavy Phoenix units use
a well-placed grenade to deal with their
shields for the colossi try and getting
close to negate their advantage in long
range gunfights please exercise caution
when dealing with their explosive
projection rifles their hazardous to
your health the Cabal are no pushovers
so they've sent in elite units called
sion flayers to sabotage the war mine
they're lightly armored but highly
intelligent they'll use cover and a
heavy dollop of psionic waves to blast
you down but here's a little tip areno
each flayer is vulnerable to a specific
damage type just look at the color of
their cloak for a hint and if all these
baddies don't sound like enough of a
challenge did you know the vex show up
during this strike because they do and
they're very tricksy now each of the
three guardian classes can bring
something special to dust palace titans
can protect their buddies from all that
heavy fire with void shields warlocks
use nova bomb to vaporize the resistance
and hunters keep looking pretty no
actually use arc blades to cut through
the Cabal enemy lines that's way more
helpful
work no bungee is designed dust palace
to be highly replayable not only does a
single run take about 30 minutes but
major combatants and the Cabal captains
spawn randomly so your runs through dust
palace will be unique and of course this
strike offers rewards like game-changing
loot that includes the PlayStation
exclusive gear like a Monte Carlo exotic
auto rifle or the Hawkmoon hand cannon
with names that badass how could you go
wrong the correct answer is you can't
there can be no wrong going to take on
the PlayStation exclusive dust palace
yourself join the Guardians when destiny
launches on September 9th
close things
you